[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY YE: Developers
looking for a way
to store secrets for
their applications
like credentials often turn to
the popular secret management
tool HashiCorp
Vault. In this video,
we'll cover how to authenticate
the HashiCorp Vault using
Google Cloud Credentials.
I'm Emily, an engineer
working on Google Cloud
Platform and open source
integrations between Cloud
and HashiCorp Vault.
ANDY MANOSKE: And I'm Andy, a
product manager at HashiCorp
and the Vault team.
Vault is a secrets
management tool
that enables organizations
to essentially secure, store,
and access control
secrets across distributed
infrastructure and applications.
EMILY YE: In the last video,
we deployed our '80s video game
application Hyperspace on Google
Cloud Platform using Terraform.
Today we'll be changing gears a
bit and talking about security.
Let's say we launched Hyperspace
a year ago to great success,
and now we're looking to
monetize our game by letting
players buy extra lives.
In order to do that, we
need to accept payments.
However, the API key
to our payment gateway
is very sensitive.
If we were to lose
it, someone malicious
could possibly steal our money.
This payments API key
is what many developers
refer to as a secret.
We hear this use case
a lot from customers.
How should I securely
store secrets
that my applications
need at build or runtime?
Developers working in
public cloud or multicloud
environments need a way to
store credentials, configuration
files, and many other secrets
for both their applications
and themselves.
Andy's going to show us
how to solve this on GCP
using Vault, an open
source tool by HashiCorp.
ANDY MANOSKE: Yes, I am.
HashiCorp Vault manages storing,
encrypting, and managing access
to secrets.
It has multiple
authentication back ends,
which provide different options
for using your own identities
to identify users
in Vault. Vault
also has many secret
back ends for managing
different kinds of secrets,
like the payments API key.
EMILY YE: Can you explain what
an authentication back end
is, Andy?
ANDY MANOSKE: Great question.
So Vault behaves conceptually
similar to a website
with multiple
authentication methods.
Just like you can log in
with Google on a website,
administrators can
configure Vault
to allow users or machines to
log in and access other secrets
in Vault. Vault
is also pluggable,
so you can use a
built-in back end
or write your own authentication
method if you need to.
EMILY YE: That's right.
The LDAP or GitHub auth
methods are great options
for developers, since they
allow users to log in with LDAP
or a GitHub API key.
In our case, our video game
is running on GCE instances,
so the GCP auth back
end is a great choice.
ANDY MANOSKE: That
does sound perfect.
How does it work?
EMILY YE: Well,
using this back end,
developers or applications can
authenticate to Vault using
two types of GCP credentials.
The IAM option lets you use
your IAM service account,
and the Google Compute Engine,
or GCE, metadata option
allows your GCE instances
to use signed VM metadata
tokens to authenticate.
ANDY MANOSKE: So the
video game GCE service
can either use
their GCE metadata
or their associated
IAM service account
to authenticate to Vault?
EMILY YE: Yeah.
I think the GCE method
is especially cool.
Since a metadata token
can be obtained on startup
without additional
authorization,
you will need to hardcode any
initial secrets into a startup
script or set super secret
environment variables.
Yay, no hardcoding!
ANDY MANOSKE: Should we show
how the authentication back end
works?
EMILY YE: Let's do it.
All right, so for
this demo, we've
already got a Vault server up
and running on a separate GCE
instance, and
someone has already
stored our payments API
key, as you can see.
In this terminal, we first
shelled into the instance
that our Vault
server is running on.
ANDY MANOSKE: First, an
admin for your Vault server
will need to enable the
authentication back end.
EMILY YE: Next,
the back end treats
GCP as a trusted
third party, so it
needs credentials to
make calls to GCP APIs
to confirm identity.
The admin can set these
credentials using the config
endpoint.
Next, the admin
needs to add roles.
Vault has the concept of
policies, which determine
what secrets a user can access.
Roles bind these
predefined policies
to generated auth tokens
to restrict what secrets
can be accessed by a user.
On our server, we've already
added the payments policy that
allows access to our API key.
So let's add a GCE role.
ANDY MANOSKE: We mentioned that
the back end allows either GCE
instances or IAM service
accounts to authenticate.
Is that what the GCE
type argument means?
EMILY YE: That's correct.
It means the back end will
expect GCE metadata when
authenticating under this role.
We've also added a
project ID and bound zone
to only authorized
any GCE instances
in this project and zone.
We can also use things like
instance groups, labels,
or associated service accounts
to limit what instances
can log in under this role.
ANDY MANOSKE: So now the
GCP back end is set up.
How do we actually
authenticate to Vault?
EMILY YE: Let's
switch terminals.
We've shelled into one of our
game's front-end VMs here.
The GCE authentication
method requires an instance
to present an identity
metadata token.
So let's actually get this
from the metadata server.
Note that this request
doesn't require
any further authentication.
The metadata is returned on
the JSON Web Token, or JWT,
signed by Google.
This is what the raw metadata
contained in the token looks
like.
Note it includes the VM's
identifying information,
as well as an expiration time.
This JWT expires
within an hour, so we
don't have to worry that it
will be stolen and reused.
ANDY MANOSKE: Great.
Now that you have
this metadata JWT,
you can just pass into Vault and
request an authentication token
under the role that
we created earlier.
EMILY YE: Let's do that.
ANDY MANOSKE: Vault will
confirm the VM's identity
and return an auth token and
lease information showing
how long this token is valid.
EMILY YE: Now that we
have this token, we
can use it to get our
payments API key from Vault.
And now we have our API key.
So with that, we have Vault up
and running on GCP with a GCP
back end for authentication,
and our developers
can keep their
payments API key safe.
Andy, if other developers have
questions when setting this up,
where can they get
more information?
ANDY MANOSKE: So check out
vaultproject.io and look up
documentation on the
GCP auth back end.
It's been great to work
with Google Cloud on Vault.
EMILY YE: Thank you, Andy.
I agree.
You can also check out our blog
post linked below that details
all of your authentication
options and other HashiCorp
and Google collaborations.
See the link in the
description below.
EMILY YE AND ANDY MANOSKE: Bye.
EMILY YE: Thanks,
everyone, for watching.
We hope you found this series on
using HashiCorp Vault with GCP
helpful.
Check out the links
in the description
below, and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel.